tell them to meet me at [ __ ] 250 dog
i spent
4 25 yesterday stupid [ __ ] for what
up dude that's not in nashville daddy
we could do you went out there playing
grab ass in nashville
let me [ __ ] send it to you nick we
could do four how much was it
425 the 25 is negligible though
well i did 405 too easy so i went to 425
we could do about it what about colon
curve how much you bench um
i don't bench that much but like my like
i don't really bench but
okay ever did unbelievable story huh
what's your bench
[ __ ] probably 240 245 yeah at least man
and then what about when you're on the
sauce
though i'm checking 315. no not 315.
probably 270.
i always had strong bench dude you find
me i'd be pushing up dawg
we actually had a cats in the wild of
chin and uh old pork rind working out
together
oh wow look at these
way to pump him up got him
uh he's dead lifting i just sent to nick
he's that was that those are 55s it
looks like
that's a lot of [ __ ] white 55-55 look
at this
man that's 500 something 530 maybe
oh my goodness is he really gonna do
this
we'll do it dog take the glasses off and
do it
and he has no shoes on and he's asian
what
that's actually why chin isn't here
today because he actually pulled
something in his back that's why he
wasn't able to make sense
i wish chin could do that i wish jin
could do that now i'm not trying to one
up that kid i did 600 the other day
600 pounds yeah why are y'all doing that
man you guys are definitely don't need
to be doing that much weight i don't
think
well you know someone walked by like oh
i bet you can't do this i'm like
say what and then it's on dog and then
it's on
dude y'all are [ __ ] i'll do [ __ ] 6
10. you can do [ __ ] you're going
nashville and [ __ ]
cry about it i'll do 610 in asheville
i'll do 612 out here dude
i don't give a [ __ ] you stop working
with that trainer that's getting that
ass right
to music there i am right there spotting
you because you need it
i wish that was you dog let's mark the
body harley son
that guy has the same hair as my mom
dude
how much is that 425 it's not that much
yeah probably could do more i remember i
used to do a pretty good bit
man on what
[Music]
on chest and legs you still have a bit
on chest
i used to do a pretty good bit of weight
oh i thought you said you had a bit on
it
no i don't have anything like that i
feel like you'd be good at squatting
with that ass you're building a squat
yeah
i used to squat some my back went out
dude i was moving a television
it was when they first had uh big
screens
and i was moving one ones not like today
were like
thin like the real thick heavy screens
yeah
and oh dude we were pushing this thing
across a field one of our neighbors
moved into a different neighbor
and we couldn't find like a trolley or
anything like that and so
we're just trying to literally push it
with our shoulders across this field
dude
but that fire fired your ass up and then
it was so hard
dislocated my back god damn yeah
jesus christ must've been a vizio
i don't remember what it was it was
awesome do you have flat screens in
nashville because you're pretty
you're a frugal man we got a flashlight
you're the guy with those big old-school
tvs you gotta turn the dial and [ __ ]
i got a 58 inch in there right now all
right daddy don't flex i'm too hard 58.
[Music]